Jordan in February of 22 so this is a
little over a year ago Jordan Peterson
was on the Patrick Bet David podcast
talking not about political racehorse
politics DeSantis Trump and all that but
talking about how actually there is a
new message to be heard for young people
right now that conservatives for the
first time in a long time actually have
a message to get across and that if they
do that effectively that things can get
much better and it can happen pretty
quickly I really love this answer take a
look
a better story tell a better story if
you want to get reelected is that no no
no no no no no no no
the way to re-election is through a
better story but that's not the reason
to tell it the reason to tell it is
because you believe it and for the first
time in my life really I believe this to
be the case conservatives really have
something to sell to young people
and they have the they can sell the
meaning of responsibility
because young people are bereft of
meaning
and most people find meaning in
responsibility
and and when the right talks about
responsibility they kind of do it in
that finger wagging way that makes
conservatives unpopular among young
people you should be responsible it's
like yeah you should why well because
your life is chaotic and meaningless and
you're stuck in this juvenile surreality
and it's really painful for you and
you're anxious and aimless and goalless
and then you look at people who have a
life because maybe you could have a life
and you think well what does that life
consist of it's like well you have a
committed intimate relationship there's
one you have friends that you're honest
with and and playful with so you have a
group of friends you have a job or a
career you know you you learn how to use
your life your time outside of work in a
productive engaging way you regulate
your susceptibility to the multitude of
hedonistic temptations that are in front
of you you
pay some attention to your mental and
physical health you make a goal some
goals for the future that are concrete
isn't that interesting what what
Jordan's describing right there which we
all know is kind of right like if you
take some responsibility for yourself
maybe you'll find someone that you can
fall in love with and build a family
maybe you'll find friends and co-workers
that you respect and like maybe you'll
control some of your crazier impulses
that that is the conservative message
that young people need I mean why is it
that the the progressive young people
who are now confused about their gender
and are suddenly selling uh that you
should be fat and that you shouldn't
know what the difference between boys
and girls are and you should judge
people based on the color of your skin
why are they all miserable and screaming
and unproductive and then there's this
other set of people and I meet them at
all the events that I do that are young
people who are seriously impressive
because they're putting the pieces
together that's the message that
conservatives should have the
conservatives can make that case no
bloody left isn't making that case it's
like for them responsibility is pretty
much equivalent to totalitarian
patriarchal oppression
the conservatives could just take that
say no no our institutions they're
pretty solid
maybe if you don't like what's happening
on the political front you join
a group a church the Elks the rotary
some Civic organization get in there and
do your part why not because you should
even though you should but because
well why not meet some people who are
like-minded and have a social group
foreign
[Music]